so chadras
galego im from Spain
2380 so then let's go
here again to the solid women's gan, please give it a
chance J this
variant
so so now he has
exchanged it late on
A6 that can of course
be done in all possible situations on A6 always
happy to do it
because supposedly  Here the field B6 is supposed to
be a problem
but you often can't
tell
that it's really that bad
so I'm going to copy the pieces
here to the kingside there's the
black
game so now he's
gone back to
C2
yes yes  Yes, he can of course now
try the minority attack here, but it
's not quite as easy without the dark-field bishop
in this constellation. It
takes at least a
while and I now have enough
useful moves
on the
kingside to
prevent it again for Z,
so
the tempo is
set here  you at least have a good
centralization, yes
he wants to play E4,
in fact, it could be,
no, but
it can't be that bad in the position I have
everything well in the middle,
so it's interesting, you can
do something here right here, maybe  so
knight G4 or bishop
H2 knight
G4 he has to at least react somehow
yes these are at least a few
weaknesses
here so yeah okay it's in there but
I've certainly covered that here at the moment
so
H5 H5
come on,
well
everything is pretty straight forward now  So W let's
try H4, the question is whether he
wants to react in some way with H4
himself or something like
that, although I'm not
threatening anything directly yet, so
he can still
make any normal move E4 is of course
also a possibility for white
here  right in the
center try to get counter play
so well okay let's
go over here and now he just carries on here
as if nothing was going on something like that
with
G5 yes I think you can't really dawdle around
here either
okay one
way so I  I think he's
very relaxed about everything I'm doing here,
as if there's nothing threatening here,
somehow it's so safe, but
I don't think it's safe at all, or so now
I can take it here for now. He
says
aha, okay, but then I have Springer H2
too
no so if he now takes B7 so
nonsense knight F2 I mean of course
knight F2 it's not
dangerous
yes dangerous it's a good thing bishop
H3
check
res yes king E2 queen E3 mate yes I did
n't understand either he's just
always very blunt here on the wing
continued and didn't defend himself at all
because it wasn't as
safe as we saw. It was
strange